despite the downward revision to
inflation the short-term you've still
got inflation at 2.1 percent as a bub
target right at the end you've got
constant references to excess demand at
the end of the forecast these are all
very hawkish signals and it's implying
that even though markets brought the
expected interest rate hike spur forward
and they've steepened the path that's
possibly still not enough sterling could
begin falling quite sharply and that of
course could change the whole calculus
and bring the interest rate rise forward
are they looking at the canadian dollar
where mr. Carney used to be the chief
you know they've got the puzzle there of
the currency collapsing and the Bank of
Canada still cutting interest rates
maybe that would have been an
interesting question to pop yesterday to
mr. Carney few local was happening the
UK vs what's happening in the United
States we would love to have the wage
growth that you guys had of
three-point-two percent last quarter we
would love to have the productivity
growth that is not what we have in the
United States so for many reasons the UK
should move before the Fed but currency
has everything to do with it u.s. is not
as dollar dependent as UK is on the
Sterling separates our official forecast
at the moment but the fall in commodity
prices in recent weeks really does put
that at risk now you know when we're
updating our inflation models we're now
looking at inflation numbers sub one
percent for the early part of next year
and our concern is that the bank of
union could struggle to communicate why
it should be raising rates while
completely missing it the lower bound of
its inflation target and as a result we
might be looking at mayor's are more
realistic
for the millions of people that have
variable rate mortgages it's warning to
them that at some point mortgages are
going to be more expensive therefore if
you can't afford a higher mortgage rate
fix your mortgage now so this is a
preventative measure to try and you get
the UK consumer in the right place for
what is inevitable at some point